benvenuti suoni testori in questo nuovo
video andremo a testare e approvare i
trucchetti per l'estate del canale five
minutes kraft quindi cinque minuti
creativi per ogni trucchetto potrete
votare il sondaggio in alto se approvate
il trucchetto o se non l'ho provato e
quindi se non vi piace
lasciate un bel mi piace su questo video
se volete vedere altri video in cui
testo il trucchetti live
se questo video raggiunge i 30 mila mi
piace farò un altro video in cui testo i
prossimi trucchetti e ora siete pronti
primo trucchetto per testare al meglio
questo trucchetto ho usato anch'io una
bottiglia di vetro ma penso che funzioni
con qualsiasi tipo di bottiglia con
qualsiasi materiale
ho riempito la bottiglia a metà con
dell'acqua
poi l'ho messa in orizzontale sono
andate a metterla in freezer
ho aspettato 12 ore che si congelasse
[Musica]
età da ecco qua la parte dell'acqua che
avevo messo nella bottiglia si è
congelata ma ora proviamo a riempirla
con l'acqua e vediamo per quanto tempo
resta fresca
[Musica]
bene ho riempito la bottiglia
ora posso bere l'acqua si mentre c'è il
ghiaccio sia piano piano mentre il
ghiaccio si scioglierà e l'acqua devo
dire che è rimasta fresca per un sacco
di tempo quindi decisamente approvo
questo trucchetto è molto utile e voi
l'ho provata e votate nel sondaggio de
con trucchetto
[Musica]
ok allora per testare questo trucchetto
prendiamo l'aloe vera e vi avviso che
l'aloe vera e molto appiccicosa e state
attenti anche alle spine
andiamo a tagliarla a metà con il
coltello e tara riveliamo la polpa
interna che tra l'altro è super
appiccicosa
io adoro l'aloe vera la uso per la pelle
e spalmo direttamente la foglia sulla
pelle un po più comodo come trucchetto
diciamo ma per questo trucchetto
dobbiamo togliere la polpa della foglia
e metterla da qualche parte in questo
caso ha usato un bicchiere per poi
metterla nel contenitore per creare i
cubetti di ghiaccio
quindi sono riuscita a togliere la polpa
anche sfera supera pc cosa infatti ora
come potete vedere sembra modi from evil
si appiccicava ovunque non è stato molto
semplice ma devo dire che il ce l'ho
fatta
ok una volta che avete preso tutto il
motto di troll cioè volevo dire la polpa
dell'aloe vera e l'avete messa dentro un
bicchiere o un contenitore ho aggiunto
un po d'acqua perché la consistenza era
troppo solida quindi aggiunto un po
d'acqua per renderlo un po più liquido e
poterlo mettere nel vasto ietto che crea
i cubetti di ghiaccio che non so come si
chiama e poterla congelare halo anche
mischiata un pochino con il coltello per
cercare di tagli usarla e separarla un
po
[Musica]
ed ecco questo versando il contenuto di
acqua e halo è vero allora ruffalo e
vero contenitore per i cubetti di
ghiaccio ma come potete vedere rivale
vas e tenco all'ata sembra bava di
lumaca e quindi ho dovuto cercare di
separare separarla un pochino ma alla
fine ci sono riuscita ed ecco chi c'era
qua sotto curiosone che voleva vedere
cosa stavo facendo comunque dopo un paio
di ore si sono creati cubetti di
ghiaccio di acqua e aloe vera io
purtroppo non avevo nessuna bruciatura
su cui testarli quindi l'ho
semplicemente testato sulla mia gamba
devo dire comunque che sono super carini
a forma di cuore non passato sulla gamba
devo dire che è la sensazione era super
fresca trucchetto numero 3
[Musica]
ok per questo trucchetto preso le mie
infradito scusate ma sono un po vecchie
è praticamente se si stacca il pezzo
dell'infradito davanti rischiate di
cadere come avete visto nel trucchetto
di five minutes kraft quindi ho preso
una graffetta e l'omessa attorno al
cosino l'infradito
e devo dire che ha funzionato benissimo
potevo camminare tranquillamente
normalmente quindi io approvo questo
trucchetto e voi quarto trucchetto
[Musica]
ok questo trucchetto mi è sembrato
subito geniale quindi ho preso un
lenzuolo quello che ha gli elastici
attorno
come potete vedere è stato un po
complicato sistemare il lenzuolo con
merlino perché sapete che vuole sempre
giocare e mordicchiare qualsiasi cosa
qua mi ha portato un pezzo di corteccia
e lo ha posizionato sopra il lenzuolo
vabbè comunque mentre cercavo di
sistemare il lenzuolo merlino continuava
a mordicchiarlo per questo trucchetto è
più facile sistemare il lenzuolo se
siete in due nel senso due persone umane
non una persona è un cane come in questo
caso sistemate quattro cose agli angoli
del lenzuolo in questo caso io ho preso
due borse una bottiglia è un libro è
come come potete vedere berlino le cave
e cercava di mangiare la bottiglia
[Musica]
tu qua sono quasi riusciti a sistemarlo
del tutto ma penso che lenzuolo che ho
usato non andasse molto bene forse è
troppo piccolo per che tendeva a
stringersi molto come potete vedere
secondo me l'idea è comunque super
carina soprattutto in spiaggia con la
sabbia ma magari bisogna usare un
lenzuolo un po più grande voi cosa ne
pensate la ho provato o no che tra
numero 5
[Musica]
ok questo trucchetto e supersemplice
praticamente consiste semplicemente
nell'attaccare le infradito con un
moschettone alla borsa
io le l'attaccante verso l'esterno
perché non volevo che la scuola sporca
toccasse la borsa sono che non
rimanevano molto bene vi attaccate
allora un po più in basso così non
rimanevano troppo in alto e devo dire
che questo trucchetto è abbastanza utile
voi cosa ne pensate le ho provate
trucchetto numero 6
[Musica]
ok per questo trucchetto che sembra
super divertente ho comprato un bowl
bubble che sarebbe una sorta di
palloncino bolla gigante se vi ricordate
nel video in cui giocavamo con
giocattoli giganti per 24 ore
ne avevamo già gonfiata una e guardate
la faccia di berlino non vedeva l'ora di
giocarci e di romperla subito se avete
visto quel video e sapete com'è andata a
finire comunque praticamente la prima è
gonfiata con un po d'aria giusto per
vedere se non avesse qualche buco se non
fossero sta insomma è come potete vedere
diventa enorme fantastica ma noi andremo
a riempirla d'acqua adesso per provare
appunto il trucchetto di five minutes
fraz
[Musica]
ecco qua abbiamo iniziato a riempire
d'acqua la bolla ball
avevo sempre paura che potesse esplodere
da un momento all'altro ma devo dire che
ha resistito abbastanza bene
ecco cosa sta diventando sempre più
grande
ho iniziato ad immergermi dentro e devo
dire che l'acqua era molto fredda ma ci
sta bene in questi giorni che fa così
tanto caldo è stato un po complicato
infilarsi dentro l'aula ball bubble
pensavo che questo trucchetto sarebbe
stato un po stupido invece è super
fresca è fantastico
sembra di avere una piscina personale ma
per di stare dentro uno squizzi avete
presente quei di switch che dentro hanno
un giochino una sorpresa lei sarei la
sorpresa dentro lo squeeze in qua stavo
cercando di tirare l'acqua ball bubble
un po più su solo che bisognava
riempirla ancora un po d'acqua
ok abbiamo riaperto l'acqua si sta
gonfiando ancora di più potrebbe
esplodere da un momento all'altro ed è
in questo momento che è successo il
disastro guardate bene
[Musica]
si è rotta speravo 38 e un pochino di
più perché in realtà era stato e
rilassante stare dentro era bella fresca
ero molto rinfrescante quindi approvo
anche questo trucchetto anche se molto
strano sapere miei commenti qual è il
trucchetto che vi è piaciuto di più che
vi ha divertito di più alla sat un bel
mi piace se volete che testo altri
trucchi e olio classico a4 caselline su
cui cliccare per vedere i miei altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite
buona visione ciao
[Musica]